welcome back everybody we have a new
leak for you today and let me tell you
that this one is a little odd because it
hits a lot of
notes that the original link that i
talked about in another video a couple
days ago uh did have but this one
completely omits let's get started and
i'll let you guys make the decision uh
it does expand on a lot that wasn't
originally expanded in the other uh this
was originally a portuguese leak so
excuse the english as it's a little
broken i tried fixing it real quick but
i may have missed a few spots let's get
started
the film takes place one year and two
months after the events caused by
maximoff in west view with the one
division credits scene taking place
eight months after the events in west
view and the movie starting four months
after that baron mordo follows through
on his quest to wipe out all the wizards
in the world and hunts maxima finding
her in her huts at night waiting for the
right moment to attack her he tries to
kill maximuff with magical arrows by
shooting at her but his magic has no
effect since around the hut are runes
shown in one division seeing that his
attempt went wrong he tries to run away
but maximoff chases him corners him and
kills him maximoff's mind is totally
corrupted by the learning's red and the
darkhold so she most often acts without
thinking when she realizes what she has
done she returns to the cabin in horror
this is followed by the marvel studios
logo maximoff finds a spell in which
that the one who conjures a creature
that inhabits it can have everything he
most desires in new york steven prepares
for christine's wedding that will take
place in half a day he is shaken that it
won't be with him but is proud that
someone will make her happy steven walks
the halls of the sanctum sanctorum
thinking about everything he lives with
christine and did not know how to enjoy
wong makes a joke about this quoting a
beyonce song in this film wang is a
sorcery supreme and steve and his
assistant since the sanctum doesn't have
the protection of the time stone wong
and dr strange arrive at the wedding of
christine palmers in new york steven
begins to feel a presence of something
and soon after we see a portal opening
near them and we see a scared girl
coming out of it accompanied by a demon
that pursues her the demon is
schumachorath but obviously as we saw in
the trailer it is garganto who was
summoned by wanda the monster is
destroying everything around it steven
saves christine after a car almost
crushes her wong and doctor strange
begin to battle with the monster while
people run away america hides juan calls
a creature in the air while steven takes
out his eye steven begins to demand
explanations from america but wong
interferes saying that she's just a
child america introduces herself wong
takes a girl to go eat steven accepts
the invitation only to gather more
information about the girl
in the pizzeria america eats as if the
world is going to end she's really tired
doctor strange interrupts a girl telling
her to eat less and start giving more
explanation america ignores him by
telling wong can i have another one of
these as you say in this universe
pepperoni steven slams on the table and
tells a girl to start talking america
says she is hungry steven says she
doesn't care because the demon
practically destroyed a city block and
almost killed the love of his life while
trying to catch a brat america mocks him
and says he didn't try to kill me but to
capture me she even asks why and says
that she will only answer if they bring
him another pizza like that wong orders
the pizza america comes to explain that
she is in another universe anyway let's
say that this pizza is the multiverse
this is my reality and this is yours
they are identical in some ways but
completely different than others steven
presses the girl asking what the
creature wanted with her she says she
doesn't know but she is sure the
intentions are not good wong explains
that the creature that was chasing
america is garganto a demon of a very
high rank in the spirit world but can
only be accessed with strong witchcraft
or by the book of black magic mostly
used by witches who do not follow their
purpose of protecting the world but have
rebelled against it wang believes that
gargantos was defeated very easily and
says that based on his studies he's not
the real gargantos and that the real
gargantuas will be coming after america
and cause a real quote-unquote nightmare
meanwhile in her hut wanda no longer
feels the presence of the creature she
summoned then in an act of desperation
she starts to flip through the book
desperately want to find a part of the
book that says to access the creatures
from another world you must have a high
level of knowledge or magic or be able
to travel between alternate realities
and worlds but this requires a high cost
wanna hear voices from the book telling
her that she needs this in order to have
her family back together so as max moff
is totally shaken emotionally and
physically she thirsts for what is
requested in the book max moff then has
an improvement in her powers but part of
her consciousness and free will are
being controlled by the book but she
does not realize maximoff then begins to
travel through parallel universes slash
realities in her astral form she passes
through many universes which would be
perfect for raising her children wanda
hears a voice in her head saying america
chavez is a key to your happiness find
the girl chavez feels that a part of her
universe is dying so stephen and wong
travel to the girls universe through her
powers when they arrive steven feels
very ill they see a wanda maximuff
totally out of her mind looking for
america juana spots them and orders them
to give her america steven mentions that
she is not the wanda that he met in the
battle against thanos wong compliments
by saying that she is not he feels that
her soul aura and spirit are being
controlled and persuaded steven tells
wong to get the girl out of there while
they try to bring wanna back to reality
wong in america travel back to their
universe and go to kamar taj seeking
help for the girl rinshra assists wong
on the spot meanwhile in america's
universe stephen asks wanda why she
needs the girl max moff says that the
girl is the key to reaching her children
steven tells wander what she thinks she
lived through was just a fantasy stephen
tells wanda what she thinks she lived
through was just a fantasy and it's not
possible to bring it to reality in an
active rage maxima fights him wanda is
trying to reach her children but she can
only travel through the multiverse in
astral projection and she must travel
with her whole body to reach her
children the only possible option is
america chavez who can create portals
between world that's why wanda wants the
girls so badly in kamartage wang
consults with other wizards and people
high in power and discovers that the
book of the damned the darkhold is
responsible for wanda's behavior steve s
wong for help by thought he is in
trouble wong tells america that strange
is in trouble america trying to help
opens the portal to where stephen is but
wanda answers a portal trying to catch
america the wizards try to attack wanda
but she puts an end to them wang totally
moved cries for seeing such good people
having such a horrible end wang is
targeted and captured by wanda while
strange and chavez escape stephen and
america travel into multiple realities
until they arrive in one where mordo is
the master of the mystical arts mordo
imprisons them for destabilizing reality
mortal imprisons america in a type of
magical prison where she is under the
supervision of clea mordo takes dr
strange to the illuminati who protect
that reality the illuminati team
consists of monica rambo captain carter
balder and professor xavier as its
leader clea is part of the group as an
advisor and faithful arm of xavier the
illuminati are debating on whether or
not to kill strange and america since he
is messing with the fabric of reality in
the multiverse which is forbidden kalia
who is also part of the team says that
chavez is a child and doesn't deserve to
die neither does strange doctor strange
then tries to warn them about wanda we
leave for a scene where wand is shown in
this we leave for a scene where wanda is
shown in this illuminati timeline with
her children they are happy and living
normally but this ends when wanda from
our universe possesses her and uses her
to get to the illuminati council wanda
arrives where the illuminati are baldr
says she is nothing but a witch out of
control and will soon be over wanda
pushes him over the wall superimposing
him and the wall similar to what happens
to cyclops and x-men apocalypse just
like the one featured in x-men animated
series captain carter prepares to cut
wanda with her sword but wanda throws
her against monic meanwhile cleo
releases america from prison and tells
the girl to stay with her xavier and
wanda begin to fight he tries to free
wanda from this reality from the wand of
his timeline in this he realizes the
evil force of the darkhold on wanda he
warns by thought to dr strange wanda
lifts xavier from his chair and we hear
cracks of bones breaking doctor strange
and mordo fight each other as mordo
blames him for it clay lifts mortal up
in the air and knocks him away cleo with
the help of america manifest the spell
and comes out of the reality with the
girl and stephen wanda in the body of
wanda from this reality returns to the
farmhouse where billy and tommy are
projecting their powers to attack her
wanda realizes that the creatures she
summoned cause all this under her
domination and leaves that wanda's body
back in a real body she realizes that
the creatures are after america for
gargantuas did not die and was alive
using wanda as her puppet she realized
that she was being used and that
gargantos will kill america and use her
powers to dominate all the universes she
lets go of wong and wang realizes that
she is now free of the creature's mind
control they go to steven america and
clia wanda asks for their forgiveness
they forgive her and recognize that she
was in a moment of weakness wanda says
that what the creatures wanted to do to
america is reminiscent of what they did
to her children then she vows to protect
america gargantos and the creatures go
to america cleo wanda and chavez make a
trio and fight the mosque stephen and
wong are the ones who finish off
gargantua stephen tells wand that he
will be willing to help with whatever
she needs wanda thanks him and says that
at the moment she has other plans and
needs to reunite with an old friend most
likely agatha america receives training
and perfecting her powers by wang and
steven clear returns to reality to try
and put things back together and then we
have information and no order of
occurrence which is loki had a cameo in
the film uh parker and harkness are
mentioned uh also the film has two
post-credits scenes
so let me know in the comments what you
guys think this was an interesting one a
little bit odd that it hit certain
points but not others possibly because
of reshoots comment down below i'd
really appreciate that stick around for
a special message
thank you so much and please subscribe i
am doing something special uh i'm
donating 25 of all money that i get from
uh my videos from here forward
i'm trying to get monetized here so i
can donate to charities that are near
and dear to my heart and i know a lot of
people love to donate out there but they
simply don't have the money uh so what i
am doing i did a video on this already
but i just want to elaborate i am
donating to a charity that you guys will
be choosing on a weekly basis
so it is important that you do watch
comment and like uh possibly share if
you can because it does help out and it
does allow us to donate as much as
possible this is something that i've
always dreamt of doing i'm finally doing
it and it's possible to you guys who do
subscribe and do participate so thank
you so much and i'll see you guys
tomorrow